wesley
uh the game itself seemed like some bit
of danger for you at some point
uh you also showed the position to you
to jeffrey afterwards that you saw maybe
an e4 option and you were analyzing did
you feel you were in danger in this game
yeah i was in slight danger i think uh
basically i expected any opening except
the london defense
so i prepared well for every other
london defense
yeah it's not really the most ambitious
opening but somehow no one expects to be
faced with the london
so i played many different setups
against it but i chose e6 and bishop d6
i think the opening when he played
bishop d3 because normally white
retreats the dark sword bishop i think
when he played bishop d3 maybe i should
play b6 first
he's slightly more accurate because
after c5 takes bishop takes i spent two
moves
moving my dark squared bishop and i lost
some time so i think i played b6 here
before two years ago in the world cup
and i think b6 is just fine for black
and then i play c5
so i was in slight danger i think i
didn't play particularly well today
but at the same time i didn't feel that
i was in that huge of a danger it's just
a slightly worse position
although i wasn't sure exactly where
jeffrey maybe maybe here is the critical
position after bishop takes d5 now the
move knight e4 flashed across our screen
yeah ah
six what were you gonna do about this
you're gonna play h6
so what do you play
six i think just backing
but h4 might have g5 g5 yeah and then so
we need the
maybe we need yes sir yeah yeah
we're going to change everything and
play bishop h7 too
uh with the check but oh that that was
what uh
i don't think that was when we really
thought jeffrey missed this opportunity
oh and then bishop a6 wow look like no
well you go back 94 i did consult uh wow
bishop didn't flash across our screen
9486 to be made by bishop a6 yeah and
the point is that after bishop e4
it did come up it did come up in the
broadcast bishop f6 knight f6 bishop c8
rook c8 why does b4 wow that's some one
move that we both missed for sure
he's annoying he always has pressure on
these cnd files so i think
a tempo you lost maybe
sorry yeah yeah moving my bishop
uh twice in the opening was no good also
because white didn't have to move this
dark squared bishop with the g3 so yeah
this was quite pleasant so maybe queen
e7 was a mistake but
black is slightly worse anyway but i
think since jeffrey missed this uh we
both didn't see this we considered
bishop f5 or bishop b5 but i think here
black
i don't know what the engine says but i
thought it was equalizing well there was
a moment though when you allowed d5
where you come up with this screen
here we were surprised when d5 appeared
as a move and uh here the move
counter-intuitive queen d6
yeah that's what i was worried about you
were worried about this okay i was just
gonna bite the bolt and take
bishop rook sd8 yeah then
hope that like again fabi obviously
colored bishops will save the day
but actually it doesn't look so bad
because i get the black light on d7 but
my knight is badly placed but if like
bishop e5 f6
bishop e7 would be seven
i thought that was knight f4
yeah i saw this
i wasn't particularly worried about
give up the knight g6 then i eliminate
this bishop
fit a bishop feet and knights
i wrote c1 bishop b7 roxanne
all right
knight before knight g6
another e4 f6 or something
but yeah the engine gives an annoying
advantage also bishop you go to c7 ah
and
instead of e7 yes sir i'm sorry rook c8
first rook c8 and bishop c7
mission 38 bishop c7
and b7 d6
wow and white is close to white is
looking to get that e5 square if
possible or
yeah i think i made quite a number of
inner choruses today on move move 24
also queen e7
also c5 in the opening
another move uh
wesley right here queen d6 kind of
counter intuitive but we were also just
thinking that well i mean jeffrey had a
pretty sweet advantage by playing a very
human move queen d4 in other words
keeping these two pawns on the board we
felt
would be very advantageous for white
ideas of d6 and bishop e5 it's not like
this pawn on e4 is
you know a big asset for you in this
what's worried about f5 though f5 and
then he was worried about f5 yeah we
were analyzing the wow
was that your intention yeah yeah okay
and then f4 e3 f3 f4
that was what he was afraid of yeah
actually i'm sure
after f5 i'm sure computer gives
advantage but not easy to play over the
board because you have to move the
bishop right and then i play f4
then you have to move the knight i don't
know where
and now d5 pawn is hanging
pawn on d5 is hank yeah and that was
like
this was on our radar
friendly left alejandra i think we were
looking we got we we got attracted to
other things
uh and
we were wrong
that's the way it works that's why i
think queen d6 is much stronger here
because you trade queens
and then you get this very strong knight
exactly so i was worried about windy six
but right he didn't
i don't think he considered it seriously
i'm not sure why
well he did manage then to liquidate
down i think there was one other
momentary problem with taking on d5 but
yeah day one they said now yeah uh
you got three rounds to go
we know if you come in third place you
win the tour
are you thinking about that at all or
you just want to
play the rest of the tournament
yeah yeah i just want to play some good
gifts
yeah i think if i get fourth place i
basically win the tour because it's very
it's almost impossible for shaq to win
clear first
um
and uh
if maxim finishes clear first and i
finish fifth then he wins the tour
but obviously the most important thing
is to play some good chess assistant
opening ceremony whoever wins the
granchester should be very deserving
today i'm quite disappointed with my
game
so i just have to
play better keep playing better
at the same time it'll be nice to win a
grand chess store but
you can't always have what you want
in life so you just gotta keep fighting
and playing and there's always another
game but it'll be nice of course but i
have to play better
all right well we look forward to seeing
that chess tomorrow good luck thank you
thank you wesley for joining us